they just sold a house in l.a called the
one
and it's a great story oh they
subscribed to the la times they sold it
um
and
the thing about this house is the
builder
is in a shitload of debt if you go to
the la times article which you're not
subscribed to
but i'll give you the time to subscribe
right now for one dollar for six months
what publications are you subscribed to
for the good of the show
wall street journal i finally signed up
for here's what you no no this is what
you should be subscribed to and i'm not
kidding okay and you can submit this and
i'll pay for it like i do everything
else
here's what you should literally be
subscribed to the new york times the la
times the wall street journal probably
the miami herald chicago tribune
[ __ ] especially because of lightfoot
the chicago tribune
um the boston globe like you should
subscribe like 10 or 20 papers truly
okay you know even the cleveland plain
dealer
because there's stories in there okay
you know what i mean but again i know
it's
it's your like how do we
do less spend less do it on the cheap
well this is my one of six free articles
for the month for la times well is that
the way to build a show no into an
empire it is not trying to do have a six
free articles no
that's right
thank you
well this article is cool because the
guy
that built this house took a
a 90 million dollar subprime loan
from a company called westlake financial
which does hard money loans which means
loans you can't get in the traditional
banking system
so the developer took this loan and then
he went wild i mean he built this
massive home it's a hundred thousand
square feet
it's grotesque and heinous vulgar
and this guy
then had trouble selling it so then he
was like hey he went to westlake
financial he's like
and this guy's a billionaire that is
building the home and he goes well hey
why don't i
why don't i just live in the house and
we'll do i swear to god this is all in
the article he goes we'll do
celebrity boxing events we'll make our
money another way we don't have to sell
it we won't flip it i got in too deep i
went too crazy i spent too much money he
goes we'll do celebrity boxing events
and then we'll do
i'll do the best entertainers in the
world michael jackson whitney houston
and they'll all be holograms
and they'll be holograms
and then people beating [ __ ] out of each
other in the backyard and then holograms
of michael jackson of whitney houston
and that's how we'll make our money
instead of flipping the house read a
little bit of the article it's kind of
it is interesting when you get to this
point
where you start building things that are
this big
and again you want to sell it for more
money lift the sanctions
[Music]
okay so the mega mansion known as the
one sold thursday for 126 million at a
bankruptcy auction it's a deal by the
way 126 million for that house is a
steal
it's a steal
126 million it's a good price
it's bel air prime prime prime
that's a huge discount from 295 million
dollar listing price even with the 12
auction fee bringing the total to 141
million
it set a record for the costliest house
sold at auction but it fell well short
of the california sales record set by
venture capitalist mark andreessen who
purchased to maui malibu estate for 17.7
million so this is still
leagues uh and above wait a minute 17.7
who gives a [ __ ] why is that even in the
article
uh oh they put a period here that's
that's uh it should be 177 million yeah
i don't know why they put a period there
that doesn't make any sense
uh the most ever spent on a u.s
residence was 238 million by hedge fund
mogul ken griffin for a new york city
penthouse in 2019. right uh several
international sales have surpassed 300
million though so the buyer will be
disclosed by march 8th when paperwork
must be i hope it's putin
i pray to god it's putin
what a great show putin's in bel air
it says the buyer pool for this is very
small and with everything happening in
russia all of a sudden those russian
billionaires who may have been your best
bet to buy it are pulling out lift the
sanctions
lift the
it's not their fault they own a yacht
it's not their fault putin went a little
wacky it's not their fault
is it roman abrama which is
ibrahimovic's fault it's not he's got to
sell the chelsea football club it's not
his fault
shout out to roman abramovic
uh it says here the guy who bought it
just got a great deal he's got people
willing to pay fifty thousand dollars a
day just to do commercials and films
i mean that's going to be a long time to
make your money back that's not a good
deal at all what are you an idiot
with the realtors yeah well these people
are brand new hanky hanky who's hanky i
don't know who hank oh the largest
creditor is los angeles billionaire don
hanke who yes 106 million to the dream
project of development
scrabble subprime lender scumbag
who's who's got an office i think in the
valley right
westlake financial west side uh west
lake financial yeah and he's a real old
school scumbag and he lent this guy 90
million or something he left lynton
exactly 106 million and the lender is
owed more than 130 million in secured
debt including money he provided in
bankruptcy to repair and spiff up the
property yeah so they and now who did he
lend it to who did hanky
lend this the developer niall
naomi yeah
who's a billionaire in l.a right
i believe he's a developer let me see if
he's a billionaire i don't know if he is
he might not be
i guess he's not
if this is all happening he's an
american former film producer turned
real estate developer who was built and
sold multi-million dollar mansions did
he have a net worth oh he did point
blank interesting let me see his net
worth
net worth and niall's net worth is 6
billion yeah he's a billionaire
and they're still fighting over this
and the guy from westlake financial is
also a billionaire
interesting what's his worth don hankey
yeah don hanke
he's just an old school he's one of the
last subprime lenders
hard money baby
god it gives me a hard copy what a
beautiful thing 5.5 billion so you have
two billionaires fighting over this
house
the the debt
that was lent
to build this
by the way go google this thing it is
heinous
and i say that
fully understanding and appreciating how
ostentatious
and vulgar la holmes usually are
this is especially grotesque it is ugly
in a way that is hard to describe it is
aesthetically displeasing
it is it is a big waste of money truly
it is it is a big waste of money it is
only for
some
billionaire that wants to say
you know that they own the most
expensive
home in america and obviously this isn't
but it was supposed to be it was listed
for 295 million dollars it was supposed
to be the most expensive home in america
so again who would want that oligarch
you know
a sheik
saudi somebody
chinese amusement park tycoon russian
fertilizer magnet
it's a small buyer's pool but i mean go
look at this house and they call it the
one it is obnoxious beyond anything that
you can even
it it's not even nice
are you looking at it yeah yeah it's in
the article i mean it's it has like a
moat around it it's like
and it looks like a moat yeah it's dumb
but i'm rooting for don hankey the hard
money
lender yeah so he took over his father's
dealership in 1972 and he built the
hanky group and its main business being
westlake financial services which makes
subprime car loans here's the thing with
a guy like don hanke no matter how much
money he has
they still treat him like scum
like that other guy nyle's a developer
and he hangs out with the beautiful
people
and don hanke is just he's a sunburned
low-class scumbag he is actually i'm
looking him up no he's a real drunk
and no matter what he just he's not in
that hollywood glitterati
respected he's an unfortunate looking
guy even though he's a billionaire he's
a used car salesman he's got the stink
of used cars on him and he got swindled
into lending this nile this hollywood
playboy real estate developer film
producer probably just [ __ ] tens all
day and don
hanky
the name hanky sounds like hankerchief
you know he is just but that's why i
root for him because he's just got soot
on his red sunburnt face
and he's just trying to recoup his money
and even though he's a billionaire you
just look at him you go he's one of
those
where they just they don't want him in
the club they don't want him in the
country club they don't want him
anywhere he's got a couple of properties
in malibu but like they don't want him
anywhere
they don't want don hanky
this was expected to hit the market at
500 million when they first built it
they were mentally ill here yeah they
really took a bath here
and the buyer is gonna be revealed march
8th march 8th
who do you think it's going to be
well it's 105 000 square feet right you
have a big 50 seat theater you have nine
bedrooms multiple kitchens
this is big this is a big big place uh
it's gotta be it's gotta be so it's
probably not a russian oligarch right
yeah probably not a russian i hope it's
nancy pelosi
it's probably not a russian probably not
a russian it's an arab so it's probably
a saudi it's an arab it may not be a
saudi
it could be a qatari
somebody from the united arab emirates
it's an arab
or it's uh somebody from china
but i don't know because
everything but we won't know because
it'll just be the name of their company
their their offshore most likely unless
they want you to know they own it
they may want you to know they own it i
don't know